people want to know how do you make
money online and i'm here to tell you
see the real way to make money online is
to make how to make money online videos
that's how you make money online
confused i know let me explain
see if you watch people who know how to
make money online what are they doing
well they're making how to make money
online videos leading to the inexorable
conclusion that the only way to make
money online is to make how to make
money online videos it's basic math see
the best-selling products are products
about how to get rich quick right
and who wants to get rich quick people
who don't know how to make money online
therefore the best niche for the
best-selling product is how to make
money online videos which means only one
thing but if you're watching
how to make money online videos you're
not learning to sell a product or hack a
product or create a product you are the
product
this is because how to make money online
videos is a beautiful pyramid scheme
and if you're at the bottom you need to
learn to get at the top and the way to
get to the top
is not watching how to make money online
videos but it's learning how to make how
to make money online videos so this
really isn't about how to make money
online
it's a how to make how to make money
online video so how do you make how to
make money online videos the answer is
very simple
you get a bunch of stock images of
people making money online
you give a little voice over you tell
people some way to make money online
that doesn't work it doesn't really
matter what it is the point is you click
bait them in
baby that is a payment that i got on
paypal for
literally just using google translate
hundred dollars in paypal
cash just in the first couple hours you
can get paid to write without being a
professional
you gotta get the clickbait make a
hundred dollars a day make five hundred
dollars a day hell make ten thousand 000
a day that's how you make how to make
money online videos true enlightenment
is realizing that the only way to make
money online is to stop watching how to
make money online videos
because if you're watching how to make
money online videos you're not creating
how to make money online videos and if
you're not creating how to make money
online videos you really know how to
make money online i don't know does that
make
sense it should if not let's recap the
only way to make money online is to stop
watching how to make money online videos
and instead create how to make money
online videos
for the people who don't know how to
make money online now you might be
asking yourself how do you know they
don't know how to make money online
because they're watching videos on how
to make money
online